we're up in the foothills
and uh behind me over there is geneva
and right behind me way over in the
mountains is mont blanc
but for us the key thing right now is
just down there
down there in the uh valley
is the large hadron collider it's a bit
misty and of course the large hadron
collider is 100 meters underground so
you can't actually see it but it's
really nice to see the perspective of
that life goes on above it i think
that's fantastic
[Music]
okay so a bit of geography um we're
looking due east and uh what we can see
is the
the northernmost part of geneva and uh
and then if we move further north sort
of going north east then you see the big
expanse of the valley in that there and
that's where the bulk of the ring is so
in fact we can see most of this ring or
we know where it is so we're in an
absolutely ideal spot to try and get a
perspective
of the first of all the size of it right
it's
it's just covering lots of little
villages going around and then
just the thought that there's these
particles whistling around there it's
close to the speed of light within about
three meters per second of the speed of
light you know not much
slower than walking pace of the speed of
light
and the large hadron collider is this 27
kilometer ring
deep underground 100 meters underground
and that's where we fire
protons in both directions they're just
going around and hitting in four
different places and with a bit of luck
we'll be visiting two of them in the
next
day or so
and that's where we do our fundamental
particle physics it's where we're trying
to understand the building blocks of the
universe the shutdown at the moment this
shutdown just after just aft before
christmas in fact uh to do upgrades
because they're constantly developing
the detectors they've got new ideas
putting in new bits of kit checking
things out checking the accelerator
itself out checking all the software it
was built a commission built in 1989 the
actual um tunnel uh in which the large
hadron collider
is now placed and it was built for
another large accelerator called lep
which is the large electron positron
accelerator so that
large because it's so big 27 kilometers
and the electron positron they fired
electrons and and it's anti-particle the
positron again in opposite directions
and collided them in a series of exper
detectors and that ran through until
about 2000
when they decided
now is the time to decommission it and
move up in energy scales uh move up to
uh use protons
and which is the large hadron collider
the hadron in large hadron collider
represents the fact that you're dealing
with protons because protons are hadrons
and electrons are leptons this famous
tunnel and famous ring wasn't even built
for the large headroom it wasn't built
for it was it was built for this other
but and
then but they
it became economically you know just
imagine you again you just need to look
down there and see imagine you decided
to build another ring that that 27
kilometer ring wasn't the one you wanted
and you wanted another one even bigger
one
you know the disruption it would cause
the expense it would cause
and they did a lot of research you know
it wasn't that the the the ring which uh
was built you know has just opened in
2009 was was built devised in 2008 back
in the 1980s people began to talk about
it and so they worked out that actually
they could use this uh 27 kilometer ring
of the of lep and
by having powerful enough magnets that's
the creek that's the crucial thing by
having new powerful magnets they could
actually get the protons to the kind of
energies that you need in order to uh
re hopefully uh reconstruct the higgs
you're not telling me the lhc was built
on the cheap
it wasn't built on the cheap no we're
talking billions of euros billions of
dollars billions of pounds to uh build
it get some protons
and uh get some more protons and
first thing to note about the protons is
the composite objects
unlike lep lep was the large electron
positron collider the electron and the
positron are fundamental particles the
idea is they're not made of anything
else they there is nothing else inside
them unless you believe in string theory
and they're
they're
got strings in but
up to now they're perfectly fine as
fundamental objects protons aren't right
protons have got three quarks in each
proton and eight gluons
all
smashing together inside the proton so
they're composite so here's two of them
so if you've got two composite objects
you bring them together
what do you get smash
lots of stuff coming out okay
[Laughter]
that would have gone straight through so
the uh you you produce lots of things
oh that's lovely there are only quarks
and gluons coming into the car crash
but there are things coming out of the
car crash that aren't quarks and gluons
yeah it's amazing
it's all thanks to einstein
you know einstein told us that um the
the
you could convert mass and energy you
could think of them as being the same
thing it's probably the most famous
equation of all time e equals m c
squared
and so indeed the idea is you have the
the effectively the the energy of the
incoming
quarks and gluons which are in the
protons so the energy of the incoming
protons
that that energy can then get
redistributed it doesn't just have to go
back out into the same set of quarks and
and and gluons it can in fact
create be create if you can create
enough of it if there's enough of it you
can create a particle
of that required mass you know e equals
m c squared and if that energy is high
enough you can create a high enough
massive particle
but the the the key thing is it that
even though the majority of the stuff is
is probably the neutrons and the protons
and the quarks all recombining together
and producing what are known as showers
or jets
um you do get occasionally the higgs
but it is occasionally so for an example
of how difficult it is and
how amazing this whole thing is and the
analysis that these guys are doing
um
in one particular regime where the higgs
could be produced you actually would get
one higgs
in every 10 trillion events
that sounds like you'll never get any
higgs but remember you've got you've got
up to
a billion events a second collisions a
second happening
it actually means that you could get
higgs maybe once every three hours or so
of the experiment but that's still
massive right it's very rare to get
these higgs and then you've got to think
about how you're going to determine that
you've got it because it decays
and that's part of the big issue
but the majority of the stuff that comes
out is as you say you know known physics
it's jets and and so one of the big
things that they have to do one of the
most important things that they have to
do in these detectors is have a trigger
system they have to have a mechanism by
which they can decide whether or not an
event is useful or not given all the
billions that are shooting out every
second
how does all that energy decide okay i'm
going to reconstitute into a higgs boson
today or today i'm going to reconstitute
back into the quark i first came from
how does the energy decide and if the
energy is deciding what to reconstitute
into why isn't it always reconstituting
into the same thing yeah so because the
energy doesn't decide um
it's all on statistics
basically it's
it's not that everything's equally
probable it's it's much easier to do
some things than do other things it's
much easier for me to walk along a road
than go down one of these black runs
here without falling down and and the
chances of so what happens is the
majority of the time
everything does
what it's easiest to do
and that's why
for example the higgs is only appearing
in one in every trillion or so events
which can also produce the zed buzz on
it's that particular decay mechanism
that higgs decays to the zed which then
decays to some leptons but that process
of of the higgs doing that will only
occur in one in every trillion events
the the the collision energy is much
more likely to be redistributed another
set and you can work out that's the
beauty of this that feynman provided us
with a mechanism to work using what's
known as perturbation theory and he
provided us with a mechanism to
calculate the probabilities of these
various decay roots
so from a given particle where is it
likely to decay to this is the one
that's going to get the higgs
hadron
reflects the fact the type of particles
that have been fired around the ring
there are we classify fundamental
particles into two kind of uh
two regimes depending upon their
differences simply whether or not they
experience the strong force and
if they don't experience the strong
force then they they're part of the
lepton family if they do experience the
strong force in other words if quarks
are involved in
and gluons in in in interactions they're
called hadrons and the hadrons
themselves come in two types
mesons which are made up of two quarks a
quark and an antiquark bound together
and then baryons and we're made of the
baryons the protons and neutrons and
they're three quarks that bind together
why don't they call it the large proton
collider because there are no other
hedgerons being collided thank you brady
good question
they're not just colliding the protons
there's another set of particles which
i've forgotten to mention
which they're colliding which are ions
and so it's also
they they they're taking very h they're
taking heavy ions and firing them around
as well and they're they're pro they're
full of protons and and neutrons and so
you can't just call them uh the large
proton collider because they they also
sometimes they take they get rid of all
the protons and then put these ions in
and fire them around and there they're
trying to we'll we'll discuss this in a
bit more detail later on they're trying
to reconstruct the uh effectively what
happens in the very early universe
uh and reconstruct what's something
called the quark gluon plasma
for for an individual proton you you
don't need such a huge machine but
you're you're firing not one proton here
there's um
roughly uh between 600 million and a
billion collisions a second occurring
so you have to fire huge bunches of
these so in fact at any one time when
the when the beam is uh up and running
properly and they'll be of order 2 000
to 2 300 bunches
of particles going around in each
direction each bunch will have about 100
billion protons in them and you need a
huge amount of energy to actually manage
to do this to get so many going around
why does everyone call it the god
particle i hate that
i don't like that uh
i don't know where it was
who coined it the god particle it's just
it is the particle that people are
trying to find in some sense the
standard model isn't yet complete
um uh it's got the particles that we
that are in it we've we've found them
we've discovered them but they there's
we know that all these particles have
different masses and the higgs is the
one that's needed to give the particles
their masses and it hasn't been found so
you can't say the standard model is
complete without the higgs
and i think it's the fact that it's if
you like the one missing particle the
particle that is seen as giving
mass to everything else led to it being
calling the god particle and
it's got nothing to do with religion you
don't need god to have a higgs
you're a particle physicist you have a
tremendous interest in what happens here
at cern yeah and you love talking about
it yeah have you ever been to the large
hadron collider before i've been to cern
i've not been to the large hadron
collider as such i've not been down any
of the uh into any of the caverns i'm so
excited about it it's frightening just
going down in the cabin and i'm excited
about it
you